we see them heading to Winterfell and
they're going back is not so secret
lovers everybody is Charlie this is
gonna be my breakdown of Entertainment
Weekly's preview that they just dropped
there's a whole bunch of new details
that they give us because of a big set
visit that they went on in addition to
the material that they dropped from
season 8 so we'll do new round of the
book giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so first big thing
I'll dress some of the pictures because
there's a couple really big things that
jump out and really big Easter eggs that
blew people's minds this morning but all
the details that they gave us I just
broke down top-10 style so pictures
first obviously this big spread of them
in King's Landing isn't meant to confirm
that all these characters go to King's
Landing
it's just that they built this really
elaborate set for when they were filming
King's Landing scenes so they all took
them there for this picture which is
heavily photoshopped you know one thing
that'll tell you how photoshopped this
is is that Kit Harington is way taller
in the photo than he is in real life
look at the eyeline of all the actors
it's actually relatively equal there
aren't too many people besides Maisie
Williams Arya Stark and Tyrion that are
way shorter than everyone else or brand
who's sitting down but you'll laugh a
little bit when you see this is actually
how tall kid Harrington is when he's
standing next to sophie Turner so that's
just how much they photoshopped things
just to make the picture look a little
bit nicer everybody's in their new
costumes you get a much better look at
what those are some people's haven't
changed quite as much from season 7 I've
already done a breakdown a lot of the
costumes but the cool thing about Jon
Snow's newer outfit is that it's more of
a blend of northern and Targaryen styles
so a lot of Daenerys as new costumes are
inspired by northern style a lot of
John's costumes are inspired by Daenerys
Targaryen styles obviously they're
winking a little bit at the fact that
John is Targaryen so he's embracing his
heritage but I don't think that's what's
going on right when the season picks up
I think it's just a result of him
spending so much time with Daenerys and
them growing closer so they want to be a
little bit more like each other and
embrace each other's styles love the
Hound and Euron are the two craziest
people in this photo the only ones with
their weapons drawn like they're about
to draw blood just a little too excited
for the craziness that's to come
I love the way that they grouped the
Lannisters
together and obviously they do try to
group the Starks together but you know
because John Targaryen heritage and then
winking at all those Easter eggs he's
sort of separated from the Starks in the
picture because they're just winking at
the fact that everyone's going to find
out that he's not just a stark he's also
half Targaryen and there's obviously a
bunch of other pictures that they
release that I'll talk about as I go
through this but this is just the big
one in the fact that King's Landing just
looks so spectacular in this set behind
them one of my other favorite pictures
though is the Clegane Bowl picture that
they did obviously they want to hype it
up and they've been watching all the
fans get excited about clicking bowls so
they're just winking at that a little
bit this picture of Daenerys on
horseback leading her army is probably
when they're arriving at Winterfell I
did kind of wonder whether or not she
would ride the dragon in but I think it
makes more sense that they're on
horseback because it's a little more
conducive to conversation so John can
kind of prepare her for what she's in
for when she meets his family and all
the Lords of the north and it's not
quite as threatening to the people that
are at Winterfell
right now if Daenerys were to fly in
like she flew into the dragon pit at the
end of season 7 this picture of Brienne
and davos kind of looks like it's
happening outside because there's so
much sunlight on them so this just looks
like it could be in the courtyard when
everyone's meeting for the first time
just because they look of concern on
Brienne's face and if you didn't see it
this morning probably the most exciting
easter egg and all this new material
that they dropped is the knight king's
poster image here if you look at the
irises of his eyes there's seven pointed
stars like the faith of the seven that
is crazy and there been a lot of people
in my timeline that have been
speculating about what that could mean
for religion in the world of Game of
Thrones I think what's going on is that
it's just winking at the idea that
everybody with their disparate religions
and gods that they worship are actually
worshiping the same primal force the
force of the old gods that the children
of the forest worship and draw on their
magic to create the night King because I
think metaphorically that just ties all
these ideas about gods religion and
supernatural forces together if it all
comes from the same place which a lot of
people have had theories about for a
long long time I'll do a separate bonus
video sometime soon digging deeper into
this idea of the night King and his
seven pointed star eyes and what's going
on with religions and Game of Thrones
and what they're trying to say about it
but it is just fascinating to see stuff
like this so moving into top ten details
that they've revealed from their big set
visit about the
first couple of episodes in the finale
starting with number 10 they say beloved
heroes lay dead outside the castle walls
talking about Winterfell because they're
talking about the big battle of
Winterfell
meaning that they'll kill off a few big
characters really early in the season no
big surprise there we all kind of
predicted that but I do have a couple
specific thoughts about who that would
be who they'll peel off before the other
really big core characters so I'll talk
about that later on my list here
number nine they said they spent a total
of ten months filming the final six
episodes the run times of the episodes
yes are way longer on average than
previous seasons but those extra four
months or so aren't gonna translate into
6 two hour movies or anything like that
I did a video a little while ago
clarifying what the people at HBO
actually said about the episodes they're
like no no no all this talk about them
being super long is overblown they'll be
much closer to the run times of the
season 7 episodes they'll be a little
bit longer than that but really close to
what the times were during season 7 so
just use that as a reference but
obviously we can assume that the finale
will be the longest episode in the
history of the show 8 David Nutter who
directed the first two episodes says
fans will not be let down there are a
lot of firsts in these episodes things
that have happened for the first time on
the show there's the funniest sequence
I've ever shot in the history of the
show
the most emotional and compelling scene
and there's one scene where there's so
many major characters together it feels
like you're watching a superhero movie
he's just talking about the first three
episodes and David Nutter the person
that just gave that quote directed the
first two the third episode was directed
by Miguel sipoc which is why we all
think that episode 3 will be the big
third Battle of Winterfell everyone has
been hyping up in these interviews 7
David Nutter also talks about a calm
before the storm episode that will
quote-unquote surprise viewers with its
play like intimacy what they mean by
play like is play as in theater play
that you would go to with a much smaller
venue where you're sitting much closer
to the actors and it's a much more
intimate experience the fact that they
call it the calm before the storm
episode I think plainly implies it's
episode 2 that they're referring to and
everyone arrives at Winterfell they get
settled in they decide on their battle
plan and then you just have a lot of
scenes between the characters walking
and talking which a long time ago there
was a joke about Game of Thrones and it
being a show about really good meetings
because early on in the seasons
for we had a lot of white walkers and a
lot of really big dragons some of the
best scenes were just of characters in a
room talking to each other six they do
confirm that episode 3 is the third big
Battle of Winterfell you could call it
the Battle of Winterfell but technically
it's the third because Stannis was the
first number two was the Battle of the
bastards number three will be the battle
against the night key and the army of
the Dead the early synopsis for the
episode just reads in the article here
the episode chronicles the great battle
of Winterfell pitting an uneasy
collection of allies against the night
king and his army of faceoff tease from
the series very first seen talking about
this scene here in the pilot episode
it's one of two in the final season
directed by Miguel Zepeda meaning that
there's another really big battle later
in the season but the second battle
isn't quite as big as this episode three
battle just continuing the synopsis it
reads here fan favorites like Jon Snow
Daenerys Targaryen
Tyrion Lannister Arya Stark Sansa Stark
and Brienne of Tarth are fighting for
their lives impossibly outnumbered
against a supernatural enemy this way a
lot of people are prematurely calling
episode 3 Game of Thrones version of the
Battle of Helm's Deep from Lord of the
Rings so number 5 they say it's the
longest battle that's ever been filmed
in Battle of Helm's Deep was 40 minutes
long meaning that this game of Thrones
battle will be longer than that and
that's largely because you're viewing it
from a lot of different point-of-view
characters so whereas during battle of
the Basterds which is another one of
their biggest episodes ever you follow
mostly Jon Snow during that then cuts a
really wide action and towards the end
of the battle you get a couple different
perspectives like Sansa Littlefinger the
Knights of the Vale but for the most
part you're seeing that whole battle
unfold from Jon Snow's perspective
number four here's we get to the other
characters Arya Starks first big battle
this big Battle of Winterfell Maisie
Williams said that the director called
her before just to make sure that she
was ready like this is gonna be the
toughest thing that you've ever filmed
your entire life be sure to prepare so
that confirms that Arya Stark gets crazy
during the battle she's got her Valyrian
dagger so obviously she'll be laying
into the whites he's also got needle the
thing about Arya though is that her
skills are tailored more to assassin and
light kills instead of really big area
of effect attacks like a giant or
someone like tormund Giantsbane just
bigger people that wield bigger larger
weapons that can swing across a much
bigger area Arya much more useful for at
the actual White Walkers that control
the whites because you do not have to
kill every last one of these hundreds of
thousands of whites you just have to
kill the White Walkers that created them
then whichever giant chunk of the army
of the Dead that white Walker is
responsible for creating will just
crumble to dust immediately so much more
important that you take down the White
Walkers in the night King then you
actually just go after each of the
whites one at a time they confirm
simultaneously because all these
point-of-view characters you'll of
course get the 3-way dragon battle
happening in the sky between Viserion
and Daenerys as remaining dragons wall
Jon Snow and everyone else is on the
ground trying to take care of the army
of the Dead
number three Dan and Dave did talk about
the finale episode six because they
directed it the interviewers did ask why
they chose to direct it themselves
because there are better directors out
there but they said that because they've
been living with the story for 11 years
thinking about the finale so they've had
a version of the ending in mind this
whole time and they were just too
worried about handing it off to some
other director to try and get right get
their vision right that they've been
living with for the last 11 years so
they figured the best option was to do
it themselves
but remember episode 3 is the biggest
battle in Miguel's appacha Nick is
directing episode 5 which is probably
another maybe smaller version of a
battle so that means that the finale
even though there might be some fighting
is it going to be a crazy huge battle
it'll be a little more intimate about
closing these storylines down we'll talk
more about finale predictions as we
actually start to get more footage but -
for all you worried about them dropping
the season a trailer they did confirm a
while ago back around the Superbowl that
they were working on a much bigger
trailer with actual footage from the
season a traditional trailer I've seen a
lot of theories about people wondering
whether or not there's going to be any
actual footage before the season comes
out yes they are pulling the taffy
trying to hold everything back that they
can but because Dan and Dave did say yes
we're working on a trailer that means
that they intend on releasing it but
number one the major character Dez that
they teased in episode 3 most likely to
be just listing them out in no
particular order
tormund Giantsbane beric Dondarrion who
just narrowly escaped the night king
during the season 7 finale they're not
absolutely critical to what's happening
later in the season at King's Landing
between all the core main characters in
there big enough fan favorites that
you'd actually care whether or not they
died so he just feels like they're gonna
kill everyone that they can that's on
that level people
that aren't critical to what's happening
in the finale but people that you care
about even though we do see them in the
photo at the end here also possible that
they kill officer Jorah Davos and brawn
but they're not super high on my list in
the way the torment in barrack are early
in the season they'll kill off way more
main characters than that so when we get
some actual footage in a trailer I'll do
more regular death predictions we should
also wonder which characters are gonna
come back as whites just maybe one or
two for the sake of shock value
everybody's wondering if we're gonna see
Hodor or white so congratulations to the
giveaway winner for my last big game of
Thrones video Diego hef please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for my new
season 8 iron throne teaser video and
click here for all my other Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer and promo
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight